foreign
house to another
there were many things I had no room for
what does one do
I rented a storage space
[Music]
filled it
years passed
occasionally I went there and looked in
but nothing happened
not a single twinge of the heart
As I Grew Older the things I cared about
grew fewer
but they were more important
so one day I decided to
undo the lock and
call the trash man
he took everything
I felt like that little donkey when his
burden is finally lifted
things
burn them
burn them
make a beautiful fire
more room in your heart for love
for the trees
for the birds who own nothing
which is the reason they can fly
there we are blue shirt one sec she's
bringing a microphone over to you okay I
have short legs I'm sorry it takes me a
minute Holly what's your name hi I'm
Robin and I'm born and raised in L.A so
we're we're not quite as connected to
all the consumerism that some people say
we are but and anyway I I was cringing
when you were reading the poem where the
woman said she had the junk people come
and take everything out of the storage
unit because For Me part of living
simply and the Simplicity movement which
we used to call it 25 years ago it's
also about that the consumerism isn't
just to be wasteful yes and that things
like trash nothing and other groups it's
we don't throw things away things that
other people can use and I find it
offensive when people talk about just in
there's one thing to throw it away and
there's one thing to share it with
others and that that has also caused me
to have a couple arguments with some
friends where I wanted their plastic
wear that they were going to throw into
the garbage where I literally took it
from the garbage and said I'll take it
home and wash it and they were one
friend of mine said no no it's my
garbage I could do what I want I said
what the [ __ ] you know I I said I'm
gonna wash it and then sometimes we use
it my family or I give it to a shelter
or it's just this idea of the
wastefulness and it does have to do with
the Earth yeah it does have to do with
this consumerous stuff yeah my wife is
also my wife is a literalist
and um I think the poem's a metaphor
and when she says burn your stuff she
doesn't mean it literally right she
means that these things are in the way
so whatever we need to do it's just not
as sexy for her to write donate and if
you can't donate it try to sell it on
eBay and if you can't sell it on eBay
have you considered Poshmark uh and also
this is something that may not apply in
every situation but if I may it could
apply in these particular conditions
here and so and now I'm getting really
boring because I'm trying to be so
precise that I cover everything and
hedge my bets I no longer become the
kind of person that's worth listening to
when I write
so the line is things
burn them burn them
because you're making more room in your
heart
right
I was talking about the line about the
the yes yeah and taking it off yeah they
can't hear you there's no microphone
um this idea it was the dumpster line
yeah these guys are going to come take
it wasn't the bird what was the
principle you you mentioned a few
moments ago it's okay don't make me do
this man you should just quote me
instead of making me saying it's mind
your own business
rule number two
and so the the point is that this is a
metaphor a metaphor for what we don't
mean literal room in our hearts
right it's making room for what's truly
important and however you want to get
rid of your things I'm all for it you
know when I talk about how to let go of
possessions the way that I do it is I
try to sell it if I can't sell it in
seven days I'll lower the price if it
doesn't sell in 30 days then I will
donate it if the person if I can't
donate the thing then I'll do my best to
recycle it and you go through that
entire process occasionally there'll
still be things that are trash I'm not
gonna hold on to trash and so I will let
that go and it'll end up in a landfill
but when I follow that process that
allows me to reappropriate the things
repurpose the things so they do find a
home if I'm not getting value from
something you're absolutely right it
doesn't mean that someone else won't get
value from it and I think that's
important to recognize there are plenty
of things that I own but if I gave it to
you you'd be like what is this clutter I
don't want this right and so when she
says burn the things trash the things
it's a metaphor for making room for
what's going on in our hearts our hearts
are very cluttered emotional clutter
spiritual clutter psychological clutter
all this internal clutter is going on
inside us and by dealing with what's
going on around us we're finally able
able to free up what's going on inside
yeah I would pause it too that you know
all of the physical things that you see
in this in this theater I mean
eventually will become trash now one of
the nice things about minimalism is the
less you consume the less waste you
produce
but once you take that item off the
shelf the damage is already done and it
does matter how you get rid of certain
like batteries you know you want to
recycle them properly you know you want
to give things the donation stores if
you can to be reused and things like
that but it doesn't matter how you're
getting rid of your things the damage to
the planet I would I would say has has
mostly been done already did you enjoy
this Standalone patreon highlight if so
you can listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free